so you're in the market to take over a
company maybe you think management can
do better maybe you want to use the
company's brand or tech for your own
gain maybe you just want to take over
the company to milk it for all it's
worth get your money leave all the
employees lives and shambles and then
leave while making it look like you're
taking it over because you think
management can do better why do you need
to wreck this company because it's
wreckable all right or maybe like a
certain multi-billionaire you're doing
it because you believe in free speech
and believe that you can run the
business better than they can but maybe
that company's board doesn't want to be
taken over maybe your offer is too low
maybe because if you take over they will
all get fired from their prestigious
positions if that's the case well I
guess you're gonna have to take over the
company by force against the will of the
board also known as a hostile takeover
hostile takeovers are usually a last
resort if a merger or friendly buyout
doesn't work and they can get pretty
messy and here's how you can do it
yourself featuring Elon Musk
way back before companies had teams of
the best lawyers on standby hostile
takeovers were pretty easy all you had
to do was buy a bunch of stock and March
into the boardroom telling everyone
they're fired you're fired we gotta
start cutting the crust off this
sandwich fire in the hall everybody come
on work
seriously you could buy up the majority
of a company's stock and there was
nothing they could do about it one of
the first people to do this was
Cornelius Vanderbilt the railway and
shipping Tycoon Cornelius owned all the
railroads in and out of New York and
when his competitors didn't submit to
him he blocked all their transfer going
in and out of New York effectively
shutting their businesses down
which led to them hemorrhaging money
every single day their stock price is
nosedived and he was right there ready
to buy up all those shares for cents on
the dollar there were literally no
safeguards against getting your company
taken from you but today companies have
developed some pretty smart defenses to
stop that from happening so we need to
be a little more strategic
foreign
hostile takeovers already have a lot of
money or at least have a rich investor
to back them they have all the cash to
invest and they get the best lawyers and
Consultants to help them the rest of us
aren't so lucky that is where Titan
comes in the investment manager for the
rest of us Titan is the world's first
direct to Consumer investment platform
for people who want their money actively
managed by an award-winning investment
team they're already managing over 750
million dollars for 50 000 ordinary
people just like you and me and is
accessible for all income levels not
just the one percents and it's super
easy to get started all you have to do
is go to the link below down the app
sign up and deposit as little as a
hundred dollars and boom you have access
to award-winning investment strategies
for us-based stocks International stocks
and crypto assets Titan's unique
strategy of identifying the rare species
of stocks known as Compounders and honey
on tights allows them to aim to grow
your Investments by 15 annually which
would imply doubling your wealth every 5
years net of fees Titan has zero
performance fees no lock-ups and a low
flat rate advisory fee and they were
even ranked as the number one Robo
advisor in 2020 by US News and for a
limited time if you use my link below
titan.com Jake you'll get 50 in your
account when you invest plus you'll get
your first three months of active
investment management for zero fees
that's titan.com Jake for your 50 credit
and zero fees thanks to Titan for
sponsoring this video
step number one to taking over a company
make a public offer and file it with the
SEC you need to make things official you
also need the target company's board to
think you know what you're doing most
friendly mergers and Acquisitions stop
here the target company might consider
your offer and negotiate and then
eventually accept it all very simple and
very boring but let's say the company
doesn't want to sell to you at all for
whatever reason that's where things get
interesting because as a powerful
businessman looking for your next
Conquest no just isn't in your
vocabulary
foreign
[Music]
you've
played nice but the company still
doesn't want to budge well it's time to
take out the big guns most companies are
influenced by the people who own a
majority or a controlling number of
shares in the company the only real way
to take control of a company against the
CEO or manager's wishes is to target the
people who own those controlling shares
here are your options
a tender offer is probably the nicest
type of hostile takeover basically you
offer to buy shares of the company you
want to control at a price that's above
the current market if the shares of a
company cost 50 you might offer 52
dollars that kind of thing now you may
be thinking isn't this just the same
thing as making an offer to buy the
company in the first place not really
you see the differences when you make a
bid to buy a company the board the
management they all get to say in
whether or not the company is sold but
when you make a tender offer it is the
shareholders who decide whether or not
to sell all you need to do is convince a
majority of the shareholders to sell to
you and you are golden it allows you to
maneuver around the board
now if a public offer isn't really your
style you can skip all of the out in the
open moves and opt for a classic public
stock buyouts basically you buy up as
much stock available on the open markets
just like Cornelius Vanderbilts the idea
is that you keep your plan a secret and
keep buying up stock until you become a
majority stakeholder of the company it's
probably the riskiest of all three
options because if anyone on the other
side finds out what you're up to you are
done
and then there's the proxy war the
messiest of all hostile takeovers here's
how it works you find common ground with
some of the company's shareholders maybe
you promised them better business under
your management maybe you promised
someone under the table deal if they
work with you maybe you hire a private
investigator to follow big shareholders
around to find stuff to Blackmail them
with theoretically of course basically
do whatever it takes to get at least
some of the shareholders on your side
and then it's time to use the
shareholders on your side to convince
the rest of the shareholders to vote in
your favor as long as your group of
trusted shareholders can convince the
majority to side with you you can take
over the company the problem usually
comes when the company's management
tries the same trick most of the time
you end up with two groups of
shareholders on opposite sides trying to
convince the other to vote for them but
if you manage to get the majority on
your side they can help you pressure the
board into selling the company to you no
matter what the management says
foreign
defense when a predator is backed into a
corner to fight back obviously as soon
as you launch your hostile takeover
prepare for the company's defense we're
not in Vanderbilt's days anymore and
companies trying to block a hostile
takeover have a lot of options first is
the poison pill defense poison pill is
basically a defensive maneuver that a
board of directors uses to prevent a
hostile takeover and basically the
simple way it works is it allows the
board to create enormous amounts of new
shares and effectively dilute the
potential hostile acquirer so that it
becomes economically unfeasible for them
to get enough shares to get control
basically once the company realizes you
want to buy up shares they suddenly
create a lot more shares out of than air
at a discount and then they sell those
discounted shares to everyone except for
you they basically give everybody except
a person that crosses a certain
ownership threshold so let's use Twitter
as an example so the Twitter's poison
pill basically says that if you get to
15 percent you're essentially locked out
from a right that then everybody else
has that effectively allows them to buy
another share of stock at I think it's a
50 discount so basically it becomes way
too expensive for you to buy the amount
of shares you would need to take over
and so what it does is it creates an
incentive to essentially almost double
the fully diluted shares outstanding of
the business and what that does is it
makes it almost impossible for the
person with 15 to then go and acquire
what's necessary to get to 50 then
there's a golden parachutes this is
where a contract is created that gives
the guys in charge massive composition
if the company merges or is sold so now
even if you manage to buy the company or
take over you'll also need to pay the
management millions of dollars extra if
your Elon Musk that doesn't really
matter because you can keep throwing
money at your problems but if you're
relying on an investor to fund your
takeover or have limited funds to use it
could end your dreams in seconds then
there's the Crown Jewel defense what
happens is the company sells off most of
his valuable assets all in an effort to
convince you to not continue your attack
they're basically defending against your
hostile takeover by committing suicide
these are nowhere near all the defenses
a company can take but they're the best
and most common another defense could be
hiring your own private investigator to
follow your attacker around to find
something blackmail them with also
theoretical if by some miracle you
manage to get past everything the
company throws at you congratulations
you have reached the finish line
foreign
[Music]
fire the executives take the
intellectual property actually try to
improve the company once you take over
the possibilities are endless now that
you've successfully executed your
hostile takeover it's time to celebrate
you've done something most Business
Leaders only dream of and now that you
have all this context it's time to take
a look at how Elon Musk approached his
hostile takeover of Twitter
foreign
hostile takeover was ridiculously
textbook he followed pretty much every
step in this guide first he bought 9.2
percent of Twitter shares that worked
out to be around 2.9 billion dollars
based on today's share price but here's
where things changed you see instead of
staking where it is nine percent he went
to turn his board and said well I'm
getting pretty close to the 15 necessary
to start the Takeover process so why not
just sell Twitter to me obviously the
Twitter execs weren't exactly excited by
the idea of having him in charge because
they offered him a board position
instead Elon accepted but in a major
reversal five days later Elon said he
would no longer be joining the board see
the catch was as a board member you can
only own 14.9 of the company's shares no
more so he wouldn't be able to make any
final decisions in the company which
went against all his plans so he
launched a full-blown hostile takeover
he immediately set up a tender offer of
43 billion dollars which works out to a
38 premium on Twitter shares he hasn't
liked a lot of facets about Twitter he
hasn't liked the things that they they
do moderate content I think he had he
has some different views on where those
bars should be e and a few hours later
he's interviewed by Ted where he talks
about why he's trying to take over the
game was on well I think it's very
important for
uh there to be an inclusive arena for
Free Speech Twitter has become kind of
the de facto Town Square so
it's just really important that people
have the both the uh the reality and the
perception uh that they are able to
speak freely within the bounds of the
law
last week when we spoke Elon um I asked
you whether you were thinking of taking
up you said no way he said I I do not
want to own Twitter it is a recipe for
misery everyone will blame me for
everything what on Earth changed no I
think I think everyone will still blame
me for everything
if something if if I acquire children
something goes wrong it's my fault it's
100 I I think there will be quite a few
arrows uh yes um it will it will be
miserable but you still want to do it I
mean I hope it's not too miserable uh
but
um
I I just think it's important to the fun
like
uh
it's important to the function of
democracy it's important to the function
of
uh the United States uh as a free
country and on many other countries and
to help actually to help freedom in the
world more broadly than the US and so I
think it's uh
it's a
you know I think this this the risk
civilizational risk
uh is decreased if Twitter the more we
can increase the trust of Twitter as a
public platform
you don't necessarily want to pay out 40
or whatever it is billion dollars in
cash you'd like them to come come with
you and and yeah it's it's I mean I mean
I could technically afford it the
following day Twitter turns down elon's
offer with one of Saudi Arabia's princes
rejecting Eli's offer in the tweets
saying that I don't believe the proposed
offer by Elon Musk comes close to the
intrinsic value of Twitter given its
growth prospects the Press is one of the
largest shareholders in Twitter this is
the complicated point it's not just
about the current share price and
there's a history in the 80s and 90s
early 90s when stocks would drop
tremendously for Market volatility
reasons or various some bad news event
or someone quits the board macro and all
of a sudden the stock price drops and
you have a hostile buyer that says oh my
God this company looks super cheap I'm
gonna come in and buy it while it's
cheap and I'll offer them a premium to
the current share price and the share
price recently may have been much higher
than the price that's being offered and
the board says you know what we're going
to get back to that share price because
the market will pick up again the things
we're working are going to grow us out
of this hole so remember it was only a
few months ago Twitter stock was trading
at 70. the stock price dropped with
Market compression we've all experienced
and the Neons come along and said I'll
offer you guys 54 bucks and the board's
like wait a few months ago we were at
70. we have all these great things we're
working on and so I'm I'm just trying to
paint the other side for everyone that
this is not just like a clear-cut which
led to one of my favorite bits on Andrew
Schultz's flagrant 2 podcast link below
this Saudi Prince that looks like Wario
just sniffed a little girl's bicycle
seat rejected elon's offer to buy
Twitter he said elon's offer which was
38 above the stock price was too little
what this guy must be dropping acid and
I'm not talking about on women trying to
drive
also of course Saudi Arabia doesn't want
Elon owning it okay they're furious at
him self-driving is a loophole to put
women behind the wheel Twitter announced
that it would defend against the
Takeover with the poison pill routes
where they would print a bunch of shares
and sell them to all the shareholders at
a discount except musk but around 10
days later Twitter announces they accept
that Elon musk's offer to acquire them
at 54.20 a share which values Twitter at
44 billion dollars the moment the news
came out training was halted for Twitter
stock musk plans to get that 44 billion
dollars through a mix of loans loans
against his stock portfolio and with his
own money keep in mind
that we musk is paying for Twitter is he
he's taking out a lot of
a lot of others are coming from other
institutions they had loans they have to
be paid back
yield gets totally cleared and he owns
Twitter
he pretty much does what he wants
ultimately he's accountable to himself
but he is going to be accountable in a
financial sense to the institutions and
people who have supported him back this
as of right now the Hostile takeover
looks complete
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you are new here my name is Jake and we
make documentaries on money power and
crime just like this one multiple times
a week for free so if you enjoyed this
one click that subscribe button below
and also click the join button if you
want more documentaries that are longer
and more controversial to the point
where I can't post them publicly there's
also a refund policy so if you join and
you don't think it's worth it I will
send you the money back just email me
that's going to wrap it up thank you so
much for watching stay dangerous out
there and I'll see you guys in the next
one
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]